هابقى الان الى القاهره وضيفنا منها من
هناك السيد هاني سليمان مدير المركز
العربي للبحوث والدراسات المختصين في شان
الايرانيه همم استاذ هاني سليمان اهلا
وسهلا بك على
همم نبدا بهذا اليوم يوم الطالب ربما هناك
رمزيه لاحياء هذا هذا اليوم وهذه الزياره
للرئيس ابراهيم الرئيسي الى جامعه طهران
لاحياء هذا اليوم ودعوه ربما ايضا من
خامنئي الى احياء ربما هذه الثوره
الثقافيه في البنيه التحتيه الايرانيه الى
كل الى ما يرمز كل ذلك
مساء الخير اهلا بحضرتك والساده المشاهدين
الكرام بالتاكيد مشاركه ابراهيم الرئيسي
تعكس حجم الازمه التي يقع فيها النظام
بشكل كبير يمكن مراسل القناه تحدث عن ان
روحاني لم يذهب الى يوم الطالب في ظل
احتجاجات في اوقات سابقا يبان وجوده في
السلطه لكن في النهايه ابراهيم نعم
ابراهيم رئيسي بحضوره اليوم الى يوم
الطالب اعتقد ان هو مرغم لان الوضع
الاحتجاجي والوضع العام يفرض هذا الحضور
لمحاوله تهدئه الاجواء ولا الارتفاع حول
مطالب المحتاجين وعكس صوره ربما ايجابيه
للنظام على عكس الحقيقه ابراهيم رئيسي
يحاول اظهار الجانب الجيد لكن هو ينسى انه
كان همم متورط في مجزره 1998 وهو متورط في
احتجاجات 2019 عندما كان رئيسا للسلطه
القضائيه وتقديم العديد من ابناء الوطن
للاعدام وهو مسؤول بحكمه وظيفته وبالتالي
هو اراد ان يرسل رسائل لتهدئه الاجواء
ومحاوله تنحيه الطلاب عن هذا الحرا- لانهم
الدع الاساسيه للحراك والطبقه الوسطى وهم
وقود الاحتجاجات في المجتمع الايراني
هذه اليد الممدوده من السلطات الى هذه
الفئه فئه الطلاب وهي فئه شاب
وحضرت بقوه في هذه الحركه الاحتجاجيه
المتواصله في ايران الى اي مدى يمكن ان
تفلح السلطات الايرانيه في ربما احتواء
الوضع عبر هذه اليد الممدوده
نعم يعني الطلاب كانوا دعامه اساسيه لجميع
الاحتجاجات السابقه في الداخل الايراني في
همم في 1999 و2005 وايضا الازمه السياسيه
في 2009 والحراج اللي من 2017 حتى الان هم
كانوا دعامه رئيسيه في هذه الحركات اعتقد
انه وقود الطبقه الوسطى والاحتجاجات في
التاريخ الايراني دعامتها الاساسيه الطلاب
والعمال بشكل اساسي وبالتالي محاوله
ابراهيم رئيسي والنظام وغزل الطلاب
ومحاوله التمرين رسائل ايجابيه اعتقد ان
هي محاوله للالتفاف وايه محاوله للمراوغه
بشكل اساسي لان يمكن في السابق ومنذ ايام
قليله تم تقديم العديد من الطلاب لاعدامات
بدون محاكمه وتم فصلهم بشكل تعسفي وملحقه
الطلاب اللي هم يتحدث اليوم رئيس يعينهم
عن انهم مستقبل الامه كانوا يقتلوا بالامس
ويقتلوا اليوم ويقتله غدا وبالتالي الوضع
متازم والنظام لا يجد سبيل سرعه تقديم بعض
التنازلات التكتيكيه وايه محاوله التقيه
بين قوسين التي يستخدمها النظام دائما لت
افعاله وتقديم بعض التنازلات المرحليه لكن
هذا لا يعكس توجه استراتيجي اونيه حقيقيه
من النظام لمحاوله استيعاب الطلاب او انه
لديه نيه لمحاوله السماعه لما طالبهم لان
النظام في مازق وهذا الامر وهذه اللهجه
المرنه هو مفروض على النظام وليست بارادته
او باختياره يا استاذ هاني سليمان مدير
المركز العربي
شكرا لك